without going through your whole career
you end up as a writer on Saturday Night
Live right and I had heard the story
that when you were at Saturday Night
Live they called you like the king of
the pitches like everyone in Saturn's
life I don't know how it works like on
Monday you all get together and pitch
ideas right right and you would always
go in with at least four ideas which as
someone in Senate like they had to
appreciate that you were that prepared
you know and you would walk in and you'd
pitch these ideas the whole room would
be rolling including Lorne Michaels the
executive producer and yet a lot of your
[ __ ] just did not make it on the air
man a lot of [ __ ] hit the floor I don't
know what has it but they were laughing
and and I've heard some of the premises
that you pitched and I like the one
about the I don't know who the guest
host was but the idea of a criminal who
wears two eye patches two eye patches
it's [ __ ] brilliant it's not crazy
it's so you know what happened I'll tell
you what happened here's what happened
coming from the stand-up world as a
comedian going into SNL instead of
coming in as a writer it's different so
when I pitch ideas for ideas
I stand up right how I would stand up
right in the great in her office
everyone would sit down and kind of
pitch their ideas I would stand up as if
I was performing my pitches so I was
standing up and pitch for ideas but I
think I broke it down after years of
thinking about it you know maybe I was
pitching ideas that only I could do yeah
did any of your [ __ ] get on me give me
your [ __ ] get on the air the stuff I got
that didn't get on the air it's crazy
you pitched an idea that I think is
genius I mean I'm talking pure genius
Johnny Knoxville is the guest the guest
host and you turn to the writing meeting
and you say okay Johnny's a detective
but he has special skills he can solve
crimes by drinking urine come on Howard
that is so [ __ ] great and it's so
it's so much truth to it all so body
your body works in a weird way Howard
it's so many things that come out of
your urine that you don't yeah we out in
the desert somewhere or way out in the
wilderness yes no I have no food no head
no no weapons to kill animal
no no fishing pole and I drink the own
BAM you're into some fire how do you
come up with an idea where Johnny
Knoxville is gonna be a urine detector
you got a look at the person first of
all right Hugh specifically he came what
happens is the host goes to everyone's
office right he's just there you tell
them your ideas sometime you don't have
an idea till you see their face now when
I saw Johnny Knoxville's face I said
there talk to him for a minute
like I'd already pissed my buddies yeah
well I saw his damn face though I said
just do it you're right but is that true
incredible it's not but you really think
that this looks like a guy who drinks
urine i watch the show man i watch the
show that kind of [ __ ] he'll drink urine
right he looks like you and drink right
it's funny you're entering show that's
when you came up hey I'll make a sketch
about a detective how did this sketch go
like what was her Johnny walks in
there's a dead body
it's a dead it's a it's a crime being
committed right they get a sample from
the from the three suspects right
and he takes drinks the urine he
actually he says other things that these
other guys did but they didn't do this
crime right you know to me yeah they
kill somebody else but when you drink
urine you always do this to your mouth
telling me they played they did this in
front of the audience and I guess I got
no laughs but you know what I think how
I I don't even bring the black book with
me but I have a list of other things
that never made it Howard
I know may one of them okay Tom Brady
was the host oh god I love this kisser
okay he's the first-ever football player
to smack another guy on the first one
ever do it no one no one understood what
was going on so why so what had
when you pitched that I did did you
pitch that to Tom Brady wait way to say
it slow down you telling me Tom Brady
was the guest host right he walks into
your office you look at him you go hey
you're the first guy in the 50s to ever
slap another football player on the ass
another man does he like that idea he
hollered man so you bring it then into
the writing meeting you write a sketch
about it and and they pass on it I wrote
it I know I went I got it twice twice I
ran that show that would have been the
first like I mentioned earlier the other
one I thought that was brilliant was and
I didn't realize it was for Jack black
when he was a guest host he's a villain
with two eye patches that's that's just
funny might know where I don't know what
happened man yeah no I'm not a good one
was this this right here man I freaking
love this one so much I just didn't know
why I didn't make it man all right this
is a Saturday Night Live Steve Carell
was a guest on the show right him and
his wife were in the military together
right right so they met as helicopter
pilots in the military right so you know
years later they get you know with a
discharge from the military they go on
to civilian life but they got married
but they still live their life as though
they are in the helicopter so how does
that feel yeah they walk over the house
over all the time